这个近距离给你们看一下
看看那这种花
这种花看到了吗蓝色
腰式松紧腰
没有口袋这款啊
来腰式半腰松紧
半腰松紧呢
来腰围64可以拉伸到90
腿围的话不用量
群场的话是40
来这个裙子9块9块
扣7扣7
抛抛裙抛抛裙
9块扣79块扣个7
来谁要谁来扣啊
来这个是个人字纹的
人字纹看他这个是人字纹
两边有口袋
这个也是春秋穿的啊
腰式半腰松紧
两边有鞋扎兜
屁股后面底边开扎
底边开扎的来这个直动裙直动裙
腰围腰围62可以拉到82
臀围98可以拉到104
群场
78来这个裙子谁要谁来扣2929扣个1
2929谁要谁来扣个1姐妹们
冲啊冲啊29扣129扣个1
来这个裙子
上面包臀底下鱼尾
逃避容的啊
军马军马面料锯纸
牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌子
这个牌子的啊腰式松紧腰两边有口袋
腰围64可以拉到86
臀围要100可以拉升到106
1106裙长87来这个裙子谁要29
扣个3
2929扣3扣3
来喜欢的姐姐衣服29扣个3
29扣个3
来这个这个青花瓷的小包裙
青花瓷的这个小包裙腰式松紧腰
腰式松紧腰这个是棉的啊
这个是棉的
棉的棉的
啊人棉33锯纸62
a and d
来这个这个牌子
来这个牌子
我来量一下腰围62可以拉到88
腿围的话是92可以拉到98
裙长的话45
来谁要9块扣3
9块9块谁要谁来扣个3
扣3扣3
XL灰色的
灰色后面有隐形拉链的
包腿呢
直动圈这个XL这个码子有点大
码子有点大
来这个应该是欧美单
腰围86 90
腿围94 98
裙长51
来这个裙子谁要9块9块
扣2扣2
喜欢的组织都9块扣个2
9块9块扣个2
来这个是西装短裙
西装面料的条纹呢有风机裤有拉链
两边有口袋左边开扎
左边开扎他这个腰围大小是可以调节
腰围大小可以调节的啊
来
面料锯纸腰围72 74
囤围92
裙长55
来这个裙子谁要9块扣5
9块9块谁要谁来扣个5
9块扣5
9元扣5
7元扣4元
8元7元
10元
12元
15元
20元
16元
12元
13元
14元
15元
16元
17元
18元
19元
20元
30元
搞到了
我把清理呼叫过来
清理清理
你来吧小妹
两个颜色都出来了
来这个蓝色的这个裙子
新款新款有裤子有拉链
两边一口袋有腰带的
腰后面是半腰松拧
前面开叉
来后面看
藏青色藏青色
来这个裙子
来吧
写的是S码
面料锯子
腰围腰围64
64可以拉到76
臀围96
可以拉伸到100
96 100
来裙长78
来这个裙子谁要谁来抠
29 29
抠个2
29藏青色的
有裤有裤有腰带
前面开叉直动裙
29谁要谁来抠个2
抠个2抠个2
谁要谁来抠29
抠个2
再听持续量一下
OK
来腰围平铺的话是64
可以拉伸到74
腿围的话96
裙长的话是
裙长78
这本来是卖39的
本来卖39的给你们29了
前面开个叉
还有腰带
锯子锯子亲爱的
面料锯子
上面标的是一个S码
但它腰是有弹力的
腰上弹力还挺大
夏天穿
就是夏天穿
我觉得这个春夏秋都可以穿
这个裙子送你了
这个裙子瑕疵很小
算了
就送给你了
看看就这一点点
看到了不
送你了
来小黄油383
不客气
多来来就行了
没事啊
来383321好谢谢
谢谢
来啦OK
它不是绿色
它是橘色
我两个颜色都给你拿
我原来我也以为是个绿
它是个橘
它是一个橘
总共就这俩色
也是也有绿看到了吗
你看你要哪个颜色
这个颜色亮一点
全棉的
我觉得这个颜色好看
我觉得这个颜色亮一点
你看你那个颜色好看
对吧
我觉得这个颜色亮一点
亮一点的好看
那这个就给你了啊
你看
这个已经便宜过来又便宜了
本来这上面便宜过去卖69元了
现在99
现在好像昨天我说的是59对吧
给你啦
好谢谢你啦
谢谢
来
也送你个小口罩
好我这里有口罩
今天送你个小礼物
来
好谢谢
检查一下
谢谢小妹
还有哪个小姐姐要的59啊
59超级划算
59扣个5
现在就这两条黄色了
就两条黄色了
就两条黄色了谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣
59 59啊
全棉全棉
来这个小黄油你扣的那个还有个灰色
还有一个灰色
灰色我看是什么嘛
也是S
面料锯纸的
腰是松紧前面有裤有拉链腰后面是半腰松紧
半腰松紧两边有喜拉兜前面开个叉灰色
灰色也好看
这个颜色很少看到的裙子
腰围62
可以拉伸到74
囤围96可以拉伸到120
囤围的话是96可以拉伸到100
寻常的话是78
来这个谁要29 29扣个2
29 29
来喜欢的姐姐就扣个2灰色灰色啊
两边有鞋扎口袋的
两边有鞋扎兜的啊这个面料薄
夏天可以穿着
来这个直筒裙
腰是半腰松紧前面有口袋
前面底边开扎
后面是光满的啥都没有
后面是光满啥都没有这是个装饰的
这个是装饰口袋盖啊
装饰的一个口袋盖
看到了不
来这个腰是半腰松紧直筒的这个裙
来
他的牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌
看到了不姐妹妹
这个牌子这个牌子
然后那是F码
面料锯纸加捐纸
腰围64
可以拉到86
臀围100
可以拉伸到102
裙长81
来这个裙子谁要29 29
扣个3
29扣个3单层嘛
有理性的
谁要谁来扣29 29扣3
扣3扣3直筒的
直筒直筒
先王说的不知道是不是这个牛仔裙
先王先王
前面这个是后面啊
后面有风机扣有拉链
来前面是两边有鞋拉口袋
两边有鞋拉口袋但是这个裙子呢下边有一点点瑕疵
就这里
这里啊有一点点瑕疵
他是一个
这个牌子的
再生纤维77
免23
再生纤维77免23
来腰围的话是66
66 70
腿围的话是104 110
104 110
裙长78
这个本来卖39的
底下有一点瑕疵来29
29扣个9
29谁要谁来扣个9
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29扣个9我看先王说的是不是这个
他说牛仔裙牛仔裙
先王你说的牛仔裙是这个吗
来这个白色的小短裙
牌子是这个牌子的
这个面料摸着像尼龙的我看一下他水洗标
水洗标写的
玩
写的棉100
免100啊
L码
全棉100的短裙前面有拉链
有裤子的啊
里边有个裤子
来这一款有封地裤有拉链
两边有口袋屁股后面有口袋
看他屁股后面是这样子的
屁股后面有口袋
来这一款我来量一下谁要给大家秒杀
来
腰围78 80
臀围98 100
裙长的话是34
来这个谁要9块9块
扣1扣1啊